انا مباشره الان الى هذه الصور من امام
قصر
العدل في بيروت حيث ينظم اهالي ضحايا
انفجار مرفا بيروت اعتصاما
للمطالبه بصوت التحقيق في قضيه التحقيق
ودعم النساء ايضا الذي استنفه المحقق
العدل قاضي
البيطار تشارك في هذا الاعتصام حسب الكثير
من المعلومات عدد من النواب وكذلك
المواطنين والمناشطين ايضا متضامنين مع
اهالي ضحايا الانفجار كان عدد ايضا من
النواب امام وزاره العدل طالبوا بشرح ما
يحصل في القضاء خلال يومين همم الماضي من
المقرر كذلك حسب اخر المعلومات يجتمع مجلس
القضاء الاعلى اليوم للنظر في التطورات
القضائيه بعد استئناف القاضي طارق البيطار
تحقيقاته في
همم ملف انفجار بيروت وكنا قد ايضا عشرنا
الى ان هناك تعزيزات من الجيش تذهب وتصل
الى مكان هذا الاعتصام بعد اندلاع مواجهات
بين محتجين وتلامي في محيط وزاره العدل في
بيروت